bart eeckhout c'est pas compliqué je
suis dans le métro je marche des
meilleurs potes mais je vois je salue
moi je suis tout seul quand je vois un
renault est là il est avec un pote à lui
et il était il était allé deux personnes
devant moi joyent marché était et passe
devant plusieurs personnes et quand il
passe devant les gens les gens il
s'arrête et on essaie de l'interpeller
et je le vois il est là il leur fait des
gestes soin et attention il marchait
mais là je le vois je suis mort de rire
parce qu'ils marchent comme keira dans
le métro poitrine sorti comme ça avec
son pote et marché super vite on sait on
est 100 mille avoir des masses qu'ils
ont pas de masque c'est à dire tu vois
il veut montrer on est là tu vois on
dirait était dans un clip de rap
pourtant c'est moi le rappeur tu vois ce
que je veux dire là je suis pas sérieux
je suis pas du tout genre et avons été à
répondre
ils essaient de l'arrêter et où le mec
il en fait des gestes et tout bref après
un mois jeudi un petit à 26 jeunes était
son côté le regarder et elle est choquée
j'enlève mes repas de jci il se passe
quoi c'est qui et tout est une joie
c'est tanguy pauthe à zemmouri tous
genres le roman est tout parce que tu es
pour info moi ça fait quatre mois
non mais j'essaie de dire les crues mais
ça fait quatre mois que j'en le placard
bref c'est à dire moi je connais pas
très bien tu vois je l'aperçu vite fait
et tout et j'ai apprécié j avais
d'accord base accélère j'accélère un
petit peu je veux j'ai discuté un peu
avec lui tu vois ce que je veux dire
ouais c'est bien rigoler
mais écoute écoute écoute la petite
histoire parce que c'est dit comme ça
c'est marrant mais derrière ça ça cache
un autre visage de la personne que vous
apercevez en fait tu vois moi je vous
exprime de façon à ce que tout le monde
le comprenne c'est l'essentiel ça peut
faire rire on règle aussi on en est très
simple et aussi parce qu'il ya sur on
est la porte et on gravit et puis pour
moi au moins comme ça quand quelqu'un de
méchant ce que je veux en plus qu après
c'est quand même plus en plus discuté
tous les deux comme ça au moins vous
discuterez parce que tu peux acheter des
trucs à me dire alors dit bon voilà à
bonbons et j'arrive à ce niveau ouais et
là je lui dis bien sur mon téléphone ça
c'est un mec médiatique d'un mec
médiatique frérot donc sur mon téléphone
je vois c'est comme moi quand je me fais
arrêter de hors jeu le var étaient
presque tous les jours j'ai des petits
selphy tout bref si tant est qu'elle
veut te voir tu t'arrêtes tu vois ce que
je veux dire et là je lui dis ouais
tanguy et sa voix mais qui se retourne
il se retourne même pas à peine comme
dans la vidéo à kars waouh je sais pas
j'ai pas ce que m'a dit va te faire
[ __ ] au cas soit quoi sa méthode la
vidéo est l'élan vital et daniel congré
qui
mais excusez moi excusez moi en tout cas
dans la vidéo n'a pas l'impression que
vous avez bien regardé la scène de
l'espace qui ne vous parle pas d'accord
mais excusez moi
avec tout le respect que je fais des
apparences la nièvre daniel excusez moi
c'est regarder jusqu'à 16 regarder juste
assène l'escalator je suis juste
derrière lui s'il fait je l'appelle et
regarder ce qu'il fait regardez ce qu'il
dit en a quand même voilà on va te faire
[ __ ] le clash descend on a été dit
mais tu arrives quoi et où il parle à
son pote là avec qui il était chez passé
qui sait pas ce qu'il dit le mec qui
vient me voir j'ai vas-y en mode de chez
moi elle laisse tomber je pourquoi je
dis tu veux quoi toi après javier faus
et pas des manières de parler il se
retourne budget va te faire [ __ ]
dis va te faire [ __ ] déjà vance avait
provoqué 2 3 pers il ya deux trois
personnes qui voulait lui parler et puis
c'est comme ça il leur répondait comme
ça donc à partir de là ça commence à
m'énerver et il se passe ce qui se passe
dans la deuxième séquence bas je réponds
pas voilà j'ai des petites insultes
légère
[Musique]
quand même assez d origine mais tu sais
je homophobe
j'ai dix ans le pdg
non il a dix hommes est attendu
et déjà y'a un truc qu'il faut savoir
même le moment j'ai pas dit ça le [ __ ]
mais le mot sale [ __ ] dans les banlieues
dans les quartiers quand les gens me
disent ah ça le pds assez pour tout
l'est pour tous les les ce qu'ils sont
homosexuels nous considère pas ça comme
dans les quartiers et les gens considère
pas ça comme une insulte envers les
voilà mais bon je vais pas dit d'accord
à banaliser pour autant banaliser simple
voilà on le dira après partir de là bas
mais qu'est ce t'as répondra comme l'est
déjà là dans les quartiers ou pas
d'excusés mois mais ce terme pdr est
puni par la loi c'est considérés comme
homophobes il me semble que les
quartiers mais bon je ne vais pas dire
inadmissible c'est inadmissible je ne
vais pas dire on est d'accord non on ne
dit rien ce que je comprends pas après
réécoute non frères but à leur bon sang
frais on m'a déjà il veut pas utiliser
attendu alors imagine front
[Applaudissements]
c'est monsieur qui
m'a tous les êtres humains pour moi
c'est mes frères c'est bien tous les
êtres humains c'est mes frères j'ai bon
bref ça c'est une bataille que je
comprends pas oui la tête à l'air
détendu youtube où elle était mais dans
le métro n'était pas comme ça et j'ai vu
fif 600 frère
tu le phenom et dire la vérité un petit
peu moi ce que je pense ce que je pense
c'est que c'est pas directs et indirects
c'était un travail en fait c'est
suite à mon avis qu aurait dû marquer
aussi je pense qu'il est stressé
maintenant de prendre le métro j'ai vu
deux le projet il est stressé parce que
en fait l'ex et il s'est fait pointu
mais pas de masque on le reconnaît comme
des mannequins préférés le mec il est
stressé mais pas de masque
d'accord d'accord je vais parce que
baisser
c'était un peu de moi sa garde à vue
qu'elle ma fille lou 12 mois qui arrête
de mentir frais qu'ils avaient cuit de
doula la barre regarde la vidéo là la
deuxième section tanguy question
qu'est-ce que alors c'est le attention
si le sujet c'est que je n'ai pas de
masque non mais non mais
tu es stressé mais en même temps il me
badat mais il est baissé de stresser
tanguy dans le métro et taku nominal est
agressée en fait c'est ça oui c'est à
dire que oui il ya un type carré et
balbutie comme sa cuisine masque match
cette notion vous dire je te parle et
c'est avec tout ce qui se passe ces
derniers temps forcément je me méfie
voilà c'est ça donc tu as eu tout
simplement exigé me faire agresser pas
forcément mais je me suis dit bon voilà
je ne sais pas puis mes amis m'ont dit
aussi bon avancé au pire des cas voilà
on ira le voir mais en occupe pas
d'accord est en fait un ami
coucou ou pas oui j'ai fait avec m'hamed
pas tout seul mais j'ai noyé tu vas
parler il est venu me voir dit ouais
j'suis pas quoi et que ses cheveux
comment ces apports pas vécu je me
réfugiais sg car toi et s'écarter dirais
que c'était son garde du corps richement
quoi mais changent et changent tout seul
que garde d'accord sert à rien juste des
capots me voilà qui te suit après qu'ils
trouvent alors quand j'ai enlevé où
tu faisais le voyou le voyou qu'est ce
que tu attends l voyous qu'est ce que tu
voulais dire à tanguy allan watt angie
choix j'ai appris il ya pas longtemps
qu'il avait 18 piges teyara oui il ya
quatre cinq piges en arrière gt gt en
prison c'est triste à dire mais j'ai
fait plus de 17 ans de prison j'étais
dire en train de dénoncer
des conditions de la car ces rations je
vais des choses très dures voilà c'est
passé des choses vraiment dur il était
chez pat et à quel niveau cette époque
là tu as lu quelques livres aujourd'hui
j'ai vu jouer un rôle tu étais un enfant
je n'ai pas hâte et en gros moi ce que
je vais faire ce que je veux faire
comprendre ça ne fait pas des choses
c'est la conviction que j'ai un c'est
pas des choses une garde quand même ta
dignité fait pas des choses pour des
sommes d'argent j'ai vous c est ce que
j'ai vu toi c'est que tu joue un rôle tu
étais dans un métier en fait et ça tu le
sais tu le sais alors je le fais coco je
pense que tanguy ici c'est pas ça pour
l'argent parce que je sais que tanguy
justement tu es s'est passé pas facile
pour toi en ce moment oui voilà c'est
encore l'exemple parfait est parfait
pardon d'une personne qui parle sans
savoir voilà alors je fais ça c'est le
genre de prison - web s était pas assez
visibles en dehors d'eux on m'apprend
des choses mais justement comme quoi on
ne fait pas des choses pourraient
retourner parce que quand il veut pas te
répondre on est tranquille ça fait ça
que tu dis que tu as fait 17 ans de
prison il veut pas te répondre dans le
métro tulle insultes bonne maman il ya
eu entre autres officié avec un bad buzz
à la devoir s'expliquer parce que tu as
ça s'appelle comme une agression il va
pas très bien
à 19h50
il ya un truc raconte rudy coco est
inquiète inquiète ne fait pas des choses
pour retourner en prison si ça part en
sucette mais que le mec est agacé que tu
me tapes et que tu retournes encore en
prison mais avait 17 ans quand tu t'en
break dès maintenant mais pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi mais qu'il est
devant moi c'est un personnage
médiatique oui 6 non pas vraiment mais
j'ai juste envie de moi je voulais juste
pu enfin se poser une question pas si
c'était moi il me répond qu les agresser
vous n'êtes pas quand même c'est parti
cosmos et ça paraît la première fois à
gaza
s'est écrasée sur yon en
fait est en panne et quoi c'est ça que
je comprends aussi posé en mécanique et
moi je dis marché poitrine sortie non
mais sérieux mais cette parcelle mais
les mecs sont là et rigole mais je vous
parle sérieux il avait la pointe est
sortie elle était comme ça mais mais
qu'il était comme ça ait marché c'est
pas parce qu'il fait ça que tu et à toi
avec panique et gilles verdez je ne peux
pas un mec qui m'insultent ans s'est vu
dimension donc comme rigide quand on est
mené
ben non moi je vais parler un moment
donné ça rien à dire faire un moment non
mais t'es toi c'est exclu par pioneer et
2 mais je
lui dis
tu peux voilà témoin bien que je
m'énerve et je m'énerve rep ah non mais
t'es âgées ont enduré des mitards des
trucs de fou pendant 50 ans guy david
rivas il va me faire sortir de mes gonds
arrête mais n'aura pas j'ai vu qu'un
petit annonçant sur twitter j'arrive le
mec il m'a insulté dans le métro
j'arrive bien à me venger des gens dit
calme toi en plus c'est à dire un peu de
bonheur et vous sur un ring on peut
régler ça tranquillement mais dès qu'on
peut faire que du bien qu'arrivant
vallier ça que tu confiance et
vous m'avez posé quoi comme question
d'oublier alors bon
moment juste un tanguy aude et au départ
soit là c'est skype à curico je pense
que tu es ce que c'est toi qui l'a
insulté parce que tu pensais qu'ils
voile alors je les ai pas insulter de
façon n'y avait qu'à voir dans sa petite
vidéo la voilà je n'insulte pas je lui
parle même pas d'ailleurs mon pote
qu'avec moi me dit non mais répond pas
ce type là attendent occupa voilà tu
vois bien qu'ils qui est là pour te
faire chier lui réponds pas que je vais
pas je vais pas répondu clairement donné
l'assist elle insistait de loin donc je
vais dis très clairement je fais pas
d'idée sur [ __ ] je vais différentes
agl très clairement donc voilà c'est un
peu c'est un peu plus soft et en plus ou
alors est donc
voilà tout simplement
la vérité
c'est un vrai me touche mais classe
affaire de fous tu m'insultes palme on
le voit dans la vidéo
faire [ __ ] on le voit il allait te
faire [ __ ] hymne à jean
[Applaudissements]
juste
dire que tu fais pas ça pour l'argent je
sais comment tu sais tu t'en tu galères
un peu d'ailleurs oui je sais que tu
n'es plus citées par an c'était plus
était parvenu toujours mais qu'est ce
qui se passe parce que même cette voie
là ces derniers jours
c'est un peu compliqué mais non mariés
vous alors voilà c'est compliqué donc
nommé comme ça pour dire je fais tu sais
tu sais ça coûte de l'argent tout ça de
faire éric de suivre les midis personne
ne te paye les meetings est ce que les
dépotoirs moi ce que
à ce que certaines personnes peuvent
affirmer je suis pas payé pour ce que je
fais ni quoi que ce soit en même temps
les placements les transports les
bernois bosch noctis à ces
jeunes avaient
été des frais pas pour ça non non non
non continua sur les 1100 tout n'est pas
défini
donc à un moment sacré terminé 1-1 non
mais donc mais on semble évident dit
je fais comme je peux mais ça me voilà
que tu gagnes tu habites comment comme
je peux ce que je vous dis voilà ce que
je fais comme je cumule du taf je
cherche juste à temps soit médecine
non
non je tiens pas devenir
bientôt enfin que non mais j'en ferais
devenir collègues pourront
toujours travailler oui moi je suis
auteur interprète un bois tu connais tu
voulais que ça soit avec toi
ce que tu veux j t'inquiète on trouve ya
au quartier appelé un truc à faire dans
la musique ya des choses à faire quoi
pour prendre
sa suite la peine que tanguy soutient
eric zemmour parce que j'ai l'impression
que tu as envie quand même envie de lui
dire viens avec nous vient travailler
que moi tu sais je vais te dire la
vérité cyril je veux dire la vérité je
vais dire la vérité
janvier à la base je suis là mais c'est
même pâté je suis là en fait moi je suis
content je suis content que tu m'a
invité je suis content de te voir je
vous suivez beaucoup quand j'étais
là-bas voilà c'est une grosse bouffée de
la bahia beaucoup de gens qui vous
suivent ans elle leur avait connu je
suis content d'être là parce que en mi
temps 10 pour moi c'est un mec un petit
peu perdu mais après il suit yves il
suit qui veut j'en ai vraiment rien à
cirer ne pas donner de leçons et ses
mots si je suis sorti zemmour je les
croisais deux fois zemmour j'ai croisé
deux fois il parle pas il a jamais parlé
de moi on s'est vus gilles m'a pas parlé
je vais pas parler
n'a pas envie d'être un donneur de
leçons fait chacun fait ce qu'il veut
chacun fait ce qu'il veut y en a rien à
faire - la base est juste prendre à ses
pieds avec me collait pas non mais bon
je voulais en fait je voulais juste lui
dire pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passe
parce que j'ai encore tout le monde
tanguy tanguy et je voulais dire qu'est
ce qui se passe j'ai entendu fait et qui
je ne connais pas mais voilà c'est
encore un renoi j'entends vente juge t
ça parle beaucoup dans les volets géante
en plein programme c'est sûr et sur
internet donc je voulais savoir l'équipe
mais justement au causse et bien
d'assurer ce soir parce que ce qui
arrive à tanguy qui se fasse agresser
etc c'est bien ce que tu dis toi tu dis
je m'en fous il fait ce qu'il veut
si tu veux m'en fous s'agresser tout le
temps passé en sera gré c'est
franchement après chacun est libre de
ses choix j'ai envie de dire se faire
agresser quand tu peux te faire agresser
ça dépend ce que tu dis aussi faut faire
attention quand tu parles tu es là je
suis dit je vais te donner un exemple
j'ai vu un mec là qui s'amusent à danser
et dans des églises et un peu partout
j'ai adressé par d des croyants des
chrétiens ou des voiles au mieux tu l'as
cherché un petit peu oui c'est pour se
faire un prénom pour dire suprenant faut
pas faute d des folies faut que tu aies
faut le voilà c'est un peu moi je pense
que voilà tanguy au moi je vois je kiffe
continue je pense qu'il a kiffé cantal
il fait ce qu'il veut moi je ne donne
pas de leçons que jusqu'ici sans fil
mais les menaces de mort c'est
inadmissible quel que soit ce qu'on a
fait c'est sur ces réseaux auxquels il
va et la violence et ses septs et voilà
c'est pas que c'est pas pour c'est pas
pour le fait qu'ils travaillent avec les
mots et tout que j'en suis arrivé à
payer tous les différentes haleines
juste à cause du ferme ta gueule c'est
pour moi c'est un petit gamin